robin will be performing the cheryl  crowe song  if it makes you happy all right robin  i'll turn the mic over to you  let it rip robin you've got the you've  got the pipes you're the one with the  professional training all right go ahead  i don't even know where to come in all  [Music]  right  [Music]  i've been a long long way from here  for mosquitoes and drink till i was  thirsty  again we went searching  through thrift store jungles  [Music]  [Music]  i made this up i promise you  i'd never give up if it makes you  happy  [Music]  i didn't think he was that bad i don't  think she was that bad but she was good  in the verse  got it she lost it on the course but  she's lost confidence on the course but  she had it  yeah it wasn't fair yeah you weren't  there's some conviction there